mais imaginez nombre d'hôpitaux et
aurait pu rouvrir avec un milliard
d'euros rien que les tests en france en
moins alors ok pour le pad tactile
haïtien donc à 1 $ mo bennani et montiel
alors montier le porte parole du
gouvernement qu'est ce que vous avez à
la java vous dit ça évidemment ça
décrédibilise que j'ai derrière moi on
rigole je suis content que sa réussite
cette affaire monsieur philippe hawke
avait disparu des cas des cadrans donc
c'est pas mal de 8,3 cm à vous de juger
moi j'en prévois toujours à vidéo gag
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je reconnais que c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal et quand ils pas répondre
aux médias
c'est meilleur que sympathiques comme
chroniqueur de alors n'attendez pas si
c'est pas mal ce qu'il paraît tout à
fait berner voitures voilà bernard la
classe initiés pas mal voilà bravo ici
c'est drôle voilà
j'ai dû percer son enfant sûrement parce
que vous êtes très jeune je
reviens en vidéo
ils adorent et vidéo gag là oui c'était
bien
quand il parlait de fermetures de lits
évidemment quand vous savez ce que vous
êtes pour vous êtes prouve axe messi est
en train de le dire alors des bons
justement je suis fan de dire je vous
sens dossier par les villes le problème
ben oui c'est important parce qu'il
vient de dire justement qu'on va fermer
des lits le problème c'est que si tout
le monde était plus ou moins vacciner
même vacciné il y aurait moins de deux
personnes en réanimation puisqu'on sait
que c'est 80 % des gens de son dénonce
des chiffres seule personne et c'est
vrai pourquoi conserver tous ces
chiffres là à celle oms qui le dit
qu'ils aimeraient que l'om est dit ici
non non non non la lépi sérieux tu sais
ce que tu vas tu as dit que le vaccin
n'est pas et sarah rien ne semblait
fonctionner mais
ça dit le vaccin lavier 80 90 % de non
vaccinés en rien aux jours d'huile à
4000 personnes henri à l'an dernier où
il avait 0% de vacciner vous auriez eu
donc quoi quarante mille personnes en
réa avec un variant qui était plus
dangereux l'an dernier que cette année
alors qu on l avait déjà 4000 il ya un
problème évidemment qu'ils mentent
évidemment que ce chiffre pas si vous
faites le calcul aujourd'hui avec 10 %
de non vaccinés on nous dit à 4000
personnes en rien et c'est que quasiment
et l' an dernier avec 100 % de non
vaccinés par définition savait pas
commencé et il y avait quand même 4000
en riant alors alors le cas d'un meurtre
pour lequel inverse comme y avait quinze
mille 15 bns as comprend pas là
mais cyril est ce que le vaccin côté
avec 50000 quinze jours il y avait douze
mille personnes en réanimation on est à
trois cent mille 15 jours il ya quatre
mille personnes en réanimation alors